[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
June 14th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
tip for a cup of coffee or a pack of gum
Shoppers face with tipping options on
small screens at the checkout counter
are choosing not to tip and it's
creating some awkward situations Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Oyen adedoyan spoke to Baristas and
Shoppers about this so Owen most of us
leave a tip with the wait staff at a
restaurant or the Uber driver but when
did leaving a tip with the person behind
the cash register at a store become
common or at least an option
it's all about these tip screens they
are these iPad like devices at the
checkout counter that take a card
payment and they also take tips now this
is something that became really
popularized during the pandemic when
cash was being used less and cards were
being used more and so tap to pay was a
lot more popular at these checkout
screens with companies like block toast
and clover usually the cashier will spin
it around for the Shopper yeah and the
interesting thing is some of these
screens have different technology so
some of them spin around others are
facing the customer the whole time and
that's something that Baristas told me
can impact whether or not they get a tip
too so why does this become awkward if
it's an option for the Shopper what's
the issue well picture this so you are a
barista or you're a cashier and your
customer goes to pay maybe they grab
something like a little snack a cookie
or even just just a cup of black coffee
there's that awkward moment when the tip
screen appears for both parties on the
Barista side of things they they feel
like they don't want to guilt the
customer into tipping if it's just for a
small thing they can see the tip options
also on their screen they can definitely
see it and so sometimes they'll you know
avoid eye contact with the customer
they'll maybe even skip it for the
customer to avoid an awkward
conversation in many instances they told
me that they have to explain to the
customer how not to tip them what do you
mean explain not to tip them some of
these iPad screens are formatted in a
way that the option to not leave a tip
is hard to find so in these instances
Baristas have to then lean over and show
the customer okay just hit the customize
button and then hit zero and you're all
good so what are some situations at the
counter where a shopper is unlikely to
leave a tip Baristas and these service
workers told me that for things like a
black cup of coffee or or a muffin or
something that's already pre-made they
don't usually expect a tip but for
things that are a little bit more
complicated to make like a matcha latte
for example which has gotten a lot more
popular in recent years they actually
have to hand whisk those things and
measure out portions and they feel a
little bit disappointed if they don't
get a tip when they have to actually
make something we're also seeing these
screens at convenience stores and places
where you're likely to just pick up a
pack of gum or a soda and it's really
frustrating people and agitating them
because these are things that already
don't cost a lot so tacking on an extra
dollar or more tip just feels ridiculous
for customers what's it like on the
other side of the screen now you
mentioned that the service Personnel
they see the tip amount and they see the
percentage choices that people have but
do they seem to anticipate scenarios
where things might get a little awkward
yeah braces have told me that they
always kind of anticipate the point
where customers are going to have to tip
and and sometimes that'll cause them to
skip the option altogether so that
customers don't feel awkward maybe if
they're only getting one item or
something like that other times
especially when they are serving young
customers who maybe you know have their
parents card or are borrowing money from
someone they won't expect that person to
tip so in these cases they'll maybe turn
to make the order as soon as they flip
that screen around just to avoid any
kind of interaction oh so there's some
tension in the air yes there's
definitely it's definitely a tense
situation it's not it's not easy all
right so the Shopper is staring at
tipping options the Barista or the
cashier is looking to see what tipping
percentage might be selected or they
turn their back to diffuse the situation
and then like you said there's guilt on
people's shoulders absolutely customers
are feeling guilty because they
understand that it's not the workers
fault that these screens are there and
this is something that I heard when I
spoke with professors as well as
etiquette expert it's on this topic too
so there's a little bit of that weighing
the option of should I help out this kid
who's who's working behind the register
or is this just not worth leaving a tip
at all and usually it's the workers job
to kind of decide for the customer am I
going to just skip this so that they
don't have to deal with it or am I gonna
maybe explain to them how this works now
in your reporting you wrote about the
fact that there are generous tippers out
there yeah who is most likely to tip
regardless of how much is being
purchased funny enough a store manager
at a bubble tea shop
but usually people who walk in with
their little puppies are more likely to
tip and she was saying that that's
because everyone gets really excited
when they see a dog owner come in with
their dog and it usually starts up a
good banter and conversation and she's
noticed that when she's got a good
banter going with a customer she's most
likely to get a good tip she also told
me that she speaks Spanish and so when
customers are coming in who also speak
Spanish speaking with them and helping
them order in that language usually
gives her a better tip as well so it's
dogs and speaking Spanish is the key
here yeah and conversations it's that
it's that good banter now you know it
might be funny to talk about all the
squirming going on here but the tips are
important for the workers bottom line
right yeah it is in many states there's
something called a tipped wage and
because these screens have really
increased the number of tips that these
workers are seeing and these
establishments are getting it can mean
that these businesses don't have to pay
their workers as much for example in New
York the minimum wage is 15. years but
businesses can pay their workers ten
dollars if tips make up the rest of that
15. and so that means that it's less
cost for the business but maybe if tips
are not coming up to that 15 level it
could also hurt the workers so oh yeah
there's all this conflicting energy
going on but what power does the
consumer have in this situation in
reporting this story I saw that it's not
that consumers don't want to tip but the
issue is they usually don't know where
this hip is going and they had a valid
point because it's almost like the Wild
Wild West with these businesses they can
choose how they want to distribute their
tips some distribute it evenly across
their workers some maybe take a portion
and distribute the rest of it to their
workers some maybe even distribute it by
the hours that a server or Barista has
worked and so it's really hard to tell
how these tips are going to be
distributed and whether or not you know
that tip that you left for your Barista
is actually going to go to your Barista
and in these cases I've been told by
workers that it's really helpful to tip
in cash if possible because they're
going to divvy out those tips before
they leave for the shift oh something
like an old-fashioned tip jar on the
counter so that might be in a jar on the
counter that might be something that you
give to the cashier or the Barista
directly the physical dollar is the
easiest and simplest way to make sure
that your tip is getting to who you're
intending for it to get to that's Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Oyen adidoyan and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
thank you